a dangerous attempt on the highway in
southern mexico to try to make this long
trip slightly easier
it's a deadly risk that's already
claimed the life of at least one member
of the group
rafael a migrant from the dominican
republic says he feels lucky to be alive
after falling from a freight trailer
i was running as a truck was passing i
climbed aboard the back and tried to
grab on but i lost consciousness and i
fell
the vast majority of people in this
group traveling in what's referred to as
a caravan are from venezuela
despite coming all the way from south
america and crossing the infamous
jungles of the darien gap many say
mexico has presented the greatest
dangers migrants refer to mexico as the
house of terror we'd rather cross a
jungle a thousand times than be here
we've been detained or arrested left
without money and if we go on our own
the cartels are something horrible
jose is from venezuela and catherine
from peru
traveling with their nine-month-old son
they're exhausted
finding food and a place to sleep is a
daily challenge
it's been painful we've suffered hunger
and thirst our child cries because he
needs a bottle of milk and more than
anything because of the sun and
dehydration
the group's leaders say they hope media
coverage of the journey will bring
attention to a worsening migrant crisis
playing out across latin america
it's been a long day of walking and
migrants are taking a break from the
intense heat in the weeksla river it's
going to be a short break because it
won't be long before the group gets back
on the road
this may be the largest group of
migrants to leave southern mexico so far
this year but it's only a small fraction
of those who make their way toward the
u.s southern border every year
and manuel is with us now live from
southern mexico manny where are you
what's happening there right now
we're in the city of weeksla uh
somewhere between 50 and 60 kilometers
north of mexico's border with guatemala
not a lot has changed since tuesday when
uh the migrant caravan arrived here in
the city it's now day three since
they've uh since they've been on the
move i want to give you a sense of where
we are right now this is a
a gymnasium a public gymnasium that's
been uh sort of refitted to accommodate
the thousands of migrants that are part
of this caravan we're talking about
people really from all over the world
but the overwhelming majority are from
venezuela the reason why the caravan has
sort of ground to a halt
until now is because organizers of the
caravan have been negotiating with the
government hoping to secure transit
visas these are humanitarian visas that
allow migrants to move freely uh through
the country without these visas migrants
run the risk of being sent back to
southern mexico back to the city of um
back to the city of tapachula
the overwhelming majority uh are willing
to wait for those visas they're quite
afraid that if they're unable to attain
them that they again run that risk of
being being sent back uh to to southern
mexico one of the things that the
organizers were telling people is to not
grow desperate yesterday on tuesday we
saw many many people as you saw in our
report sort of jumping on the back of
these freight trucks um we saw injuries
of people falling uh by the end of the
day unfortunately we also saw one man
who ended up under the wheels of a semi
truck so they're warning people not to
grow desperate they're they announce
that somewhere around 2000 people have
already left the caravan again grown
frustrated with a slow pace this group
can only move as fast as the slowest
members of the group meaning women and
children they're quite uh quite a few
families that are traveling as part of
uh as part of this caravan
what we've heard is that somewhere
around 650 of these transit visas have
been issued the government has promised
to issue 500 at a time but we are
talking about thousands of people this
is not the largest caravan today but
it's certainly uh the largest one that
we've seen so far this year um what
we're also hearing from people is that
regardless of whether or not they are
able to receive their transit visas
today or tomorrow they're going to
continue to walk
we spoke to an elderly woman in her 70s
from nicaragua who
told us that she's tired of waiting she
doesn't want to wait for a transit visa
she's going to go it on her own this is
something that is
not recommended for migrants traveling
the sense is that it's better to travel
as a group they run many many risks on
their way to the northern border and
everyone here is saying that they are
committed to reaching the u.s southern
border
algae sirius manuel rappelo reporting
live there from southern mexico and many
thanks indeed